allahar
[Silence]
ill
Sal
[Silence]
ill
alhamd
[Silence]
muham muham
sub
[Silence]
I praise
Allah and I ask him to send his peace
and His blessings upon his beloved
Prophet Muhammad sallallah alaihi his
family
members his companions and all of those
who followed his way of
life and I bear witness that there is no
God but Allah and I bear witness that
prophet Muhammed
am is his messenger and his
servant dear brothers and sisters we are
live in the days of
r a month considered to be mam a sacred
month Allah in the Quan he says
[Silence]
he talks about the number of the months
during the year to be
12 and then he
says that four of these months are
considered to be
sacred therefore during these sacred
months we should not oppress
ourselves do not oppress eles during
these sacred
months the Hadith of our beloved Prophet
[Arabic recitation]
elaborates on what these four months are
and according to the Hadith we know that
the month that we are in right now the
month of rajab is considered to be a
sacred
month sacred what does it mean
M I mean Translating that as a
sacred a lot of people they
May understand that it is an honorable
month a virtuous a virtuous month an
important month but what does really
mean and Allah subhah wa ta'ala
has explained the meaning of
it not the literal meaning of the word
mam but has
explained the deeper
meaning of what we should not
do during during the month of rajab and
the other three months by in other words
by saying what is the most important
thing that you need to know about these
months he
says do not oppress yourselves during
these months this the most important
thing that you need to learn what to do
and what mam means to you literally if
we translate the word muharam it means
to stay away from something that is
prohibited and Arabs back in the
days as many nations even nowadays as
well used to fight and the Quran tells
us so they used to I don't want to go
too much into the story but I'll try to
wrap it up very quickly in order for us
to understand what these ay from Surah
Toba they're talking about so it says
that Arabs they would consider if if
rajab for example would start tomorrow
right if RAB would start tomorrow and
rajab is one of the Sacred months they
would say well tomorrow is not rajab yet
rajab is going to start after tomorrow
why so they can
continue so they can ex they can
exceed they can go extra
day they can go an extra day and fulfill
their evil plans because
fighting fighting isil evil unless you
fighting for justice but according to
the Quran they were not just fighting
for justice most of their their fights
were based on personal reasons he said
this to me I said that to him you know
he offended me I offended him so the
tribes they would go on for months and
months and fight based on some
unimportant matters but however in order
for them to extend that right in order
for them to fulfill their their evil
fight
they would consider even these sacred
months not to start when in reality they
have
started so that's what Allah subh
criticizes here so there are two things
that we we must pay attention as we dive
deep into the interpretation of these ay
from number one
is me not as a month but muharam sacred
or to stay away from it means for me
that I should stop
oppression what kind of Oppression are
we talking about oppressing myself to
begin with if I am using prohibited
things that Allah has considered to be
Haram I should stay away from those well
brother I'm not using alcohol I don't
even consume pork these are the most
easy things that even
non-muslims sometimes don't use
there is a harm that you can pose to
your own self is through a mental
harm spiritual harm mental harm is when
you
are
thinking and continuously possessing
ideas that are harmful to your own
spiritual
values again you have ideas in your
mind you have feelings and you
continuously haror those ideas and those
feelings instead of letting those go or
instead of rejecting those
ideas what are you talking about well
I'm talking about for example hate right
somebody has done something to you
forgive nope I have Grudge I'm going to
keep it deep inside of you're hurting
your Yourself by doing
that some people they have just
simply bad ideas about let's say for
example about religion because they
don't understand certain parts of
Islam let's say for example you know
it's not normal for a person to stop
drinking for example again it may be
anything that you are harboring in your
mind whether it is towards religion or
or towards
people that does nothing to you but
harms you so Allah subhana waala wants
to call your attention during these four
sacred months for you to analyze the
matters carefully and to stop harboring
any ill
feelings or wrong ideas in your mind so
purify yourself that
way so stop the oppression towards
yourself
and then there is the other kind of
Oppression when you oppress the
others how do you oppress the others you
abuse them mentally you abuse
them spiritually you abuse them
physically as
well you call people names you keep
lying to people you deceive people you
take their rights
away you beat them up you murder them
so all of these are different forms of
demonstration of that oppression as I
was talking about and Allah subhana Waal
says do not express that
oppression now why in particularly
during these
months because the human being is
created human being is weak
not because Allah subhana wa tala is
weak and he is
creating a weak creation but purposely
the human was created weak in
order to connect with somebody who
is
strong with somebody who is who has all
the power all the
abilities that's why Allah subh created
the human weak so he can connect with
him he can depend on
him so he doesn't feel independent like
some people unfortunately behave as they
are independent from
God so as we are created like
that we we want
to better ourselves during these four
months because when we start bettering
ourselves and to begin with staying away
from
oppression which opens a door for us to
do
other oppression
Injustice being unfair whether it is to
yourself or the
others it helps you when you when you
restrict yourself you better yourself in
that matter it helps you a lot to start
achieving Good Deeds to Ed in doing
righteous
Deeds when Allah subhana wa tala says
for
example now as I stop the oppression I
can haste I can I can hurry I can run I
can compete with others in doing
righteous
Deeds when Allah subhah wa ta'ala says
stay away from the when Allah subh
says right I can be able now to connect
with all of these positive Deeds because
I have already closed the door of the
oppression oppression is very very not
just important to understand but it's
very important to close that
door a lot of Nations a lot of people
they suffer because they are
unfair and a lot of other nations even
if they are not Muslims or individuals
even if they are not Muslims even if
they don't believe in God God will still
give them in this
world because they are being
fair a Muslim can be suffering in this
world because of Injustice because of
being unfair and a
non-muslim can
receive a lot in this world because of
the
fairness which is connected strongly
with you know of being against
oppression
justice justice when you are a just
person a fair person is when you are
fighting and rejecting
oppression imagine if we would be
rejecting oppression on our selves and
the people around us imagine if Muslim
countries let alone other I mean forget
about the rest of the world just Muslim
countries they would stop ing their own
people imagine how the world would have
been the world was guided with Islamic
principles and Islam started being
spread in the most parts of the world
hundreds and hundreds of years ago
because people stood for
fairness people valued their
ethics people valued their
people value their
spirituality and millions of people
Embrace Islam because of this today we
want to be everybody
else we don't care whether we're being
fair or
not we don't care whether we are
applying our ethics or
not we don't care whether we become
spiritual people or
not we get so connected to materialism
that this world has to offer to a
certain point where we're not able to
see anymore what is what is right and
what is
wrong even within Muslim circles often
you find places where spirituality is
dead and only formalities remain but
with formalities you cannot go that
far it's not meant to be the formality
the way how you do the prayer that leads
you to Jenna or to Allah subhah wa
ta'ala
but it is meant to be that soul that
spirit that heart that you
possess the
feelings the connection with Allah
subhah wa ta'ala that you have during
that time that causes your salvation in
the Hereafter of course together with of
Allah subh
waala don't take it from me take it from
the
Quran so you don't say this guy is
all about spirituality
right the Quran is telling you this it
will be a day when the wealth and the
children they're not going to do much to
you they're not going to be able to help
you much on that day what's going to
help you on that day is the Pure Heart
The Sound
heart which leads me to the last part of
this inshallah
today and that
is connection with Allah subhah wa tala
again we want to go above the
formalities
above standing for prayer
above the the formal act
itself we want to have
that we want to have that that peace
during the prayer because this is more
is more valuable than the formal act
itself all
right so it is not it is not the way how
the apple looks I'm just bringing you a
very simple example to to elaborate a
little bit so people don't say like
you're theorizing here you're talking
about Theory and stuff when you look at
the Apple it is not the form of the
Apple that really satisfies you
sometimes some people they are satisfied
even with the the form of the apple
right that could be reality but that
shouldn't be that
way what really satisfies you or what it
should satisfy you is the Taste and at
the same time the nutritions that you
get from that Apple so similarly when
you do the prayer when you fast when you
do Hajj when you do om when you give
zakat when you read Quran when you doar
when you do duas it is not the formal
thing itself how beautifully you were
reciting the Quran but how well you are
connected with the Quran how much you
are practicing
Quran Allah subhana tala challenges
people by saying aren they
contemplating as they're
reading the prayer when he said to say
m he said perform the prayer so you can
remember me
in other words the the prayer is a tool
for you to get close to me and to be
connected with me why do we need to be
connected with him five times a day or
even more than that well because when
you are with him you're closer to Mercy
when you are with him you're closer to
forgiveness when you are with him you're
closer to
safety but when you are away from him
you're closer to what to
sins when you are away from him
you're closer to your own
nefs when you are away from him you have
opened the door for evil to get in and
to start playing around with you
w that's
why but the question is are we feeling
that closeness as we do the prayer or
not now when we are paying attention
only to formalities we start and we end
with formalities for example again
I have to be
clear giv examples when we talk
about formality it's I have to pay
attention to how well I am taking
the
right and how well I'm
reciting and how straight I'm standing
in the prayer these are all important
for sure but they still remain
formal important for
formalities otherwise sometimes if you
don't have it correct your prayer can be
invalid but again these are the
technical aspects of the
prayer what is above that is your
connection how is your connection with
Allah subhah wa ta'ala you're supposed
to recite Quran for example during the
prayer as you're having a conversation
with god you're asking him something
he's replying back to you alhamdulillah
talks about this
one you're
saying alhamd Praises be to God the lord
of the worlds God is answering back by
saying my servant has praised
me after every sentence there is after
every Ayah except the last part which is
a prayer Dua there is an answer from
Allah so you're saying something Allah
is answering you
back until you read reach the point
where he
says this is between me and my servant
and whatever my servant asks for he's
going to or she's going to
receive guide us on the straight path
the path of those who you were pleased
with not the path of those
who those who have earned your anger not
the path of those who have earned your
anger not the nor the path of those who
went astray in other words we don't want
to be a part of those two categories
it's a prayer it's a
Dua and my servant is going to receive
what he's asking
for so when you are when you are feeling
this and when you are connected with
this right when you when you see these
things when you're present with your
heart during the prayer I'm using the
prayer just as an example all the other
they require the same thing for your
heart to be present when that's
happening that's where you start to see
the
blessings not just in
prayer but after the
prayer prayer is quickly five minutes 10
minutes after the prayer what do you
mean after the prayer the way how you
talk to people Allah subhana wa taala
becomes your he assists you he helps you
he betters you because you're present
with him often you are improving the
ways how you're connecting with him
often you see so now we
say right we are relying on Allah
subhana what are you relying for you're
relying on him to take you to take you
from your hand and to lead you to to
bless bless you what does it mean to
bless you it means to give you rewards
in this world but at the same time to
show you the the straight path to give
you wisdom for example in how to do
things in a better way how to have
better relations with people why because
you're obedient to begin with towards
your creator not just in obedient
formally but in obedient to him
spiritually as well it's saying
Abdi my servant you have earned this Mak
you have been mallah a Shak a true
person of gratitude because you
constantly Express that gratitude to me
and I'm going to give you and I'm going
to better your situation I'm going to
give you hikma I'm going to give you
blessings I'm going to give you this and
that you're not anymore in charge of
yourself don't depend on
yourself you still do your homework but
the one who's going to provide the one
who's going to show you the way the one
who's gonna take you from your hand and
guide
you we don't need guidance only to
become Muslims right we say five times a
day what is that
guidance alhamdulillah we're Muslims
we're guided no there's more than just
being guide on Islam there is a guidance
of your heart on daily basis constantly
in choosing what is right and being with
the
truth in all matters
choosing what is right and being with
the truth so Allah subhana wa taala
guides you constantly towards what is
the best this is one of the
interpretations of mu Muhammad Shafi in
in very beautiful T he lines three
categories of guidance but I'm just
giving you one not going into much
details in his Quran so very beautifully
expressed
now to finalize this dear brothers and
sisters again the
ultimate the Ultimate Experience of
your enrichment of your soul of Your
Heart Right your your positive
experiences of your
spirituality is when you are connected
with Allah subhah wa taala
constantly what does it to be connected
with Allah constantly from my
understanding and experience and of
course based on the Hadith and based on
the AY from the
Quran I find four categories to be very
important for for us to help us not only
achieve but maintain that connection
number
one prioritize excuse me
prioritize
those commands
the Mandatory Actions or deeds that
we're
commanded what do I mean by
that you have a prayer for example this
is mandatory for all of
us unless we fall under certain
categories I'm not going to go into the
F perspective of who should pray and who
who is not obliged to pray but overall
we are obliged to pray so that is an
obligation
helping
somebody it is
good giving a donation it is good
performing prayer it is at least right
it's something
good but you would have people who would
be missing jum prayer for example which
is mandatory obligatory for men while at
the same time they they pay attention to
attend prayers this is just a simple
example so what do we have here going
what's wrong with this
scenario the person is not prioritizing
things
right all right so it's very important
to understand from a religious
perspective what is obligation for me as
an
individual what does Islam obligates me
with and don't tell me that is just a
prayer and just a fasting right there's
a lot
responsibilities as an individual as a
son as a daughter as a mother as a
husband as a worker as a
friend sky is the the limit there's a
lot of things that we need to pay
attention to that are considered to be
obligations not only from the
ritualistic perspective but also from a
personal perspective as well right these
have to be well understood and be
prioritized
number
two
prohibitions stay away from
prohibitions the AY that I mentioned
earlier mentions that these Arabs prior
to Prophet alam's
time
was right or similar similar statements
in in the Quran we find
often even Shayan for
example playing with their minds and
making certain things seem
okay but in reality they're not
okay your own NS tells you that it's
okay when in reality it's not
okay prohibitions those acts that are
considered to be prohibited they are
considered to be prohibited for your
benefit whether you do something good or
you do something bad that doesn't change
anything to God but it changes you it
makes you either a better person or it
makes you a worse
person so when you are doing this when
you are paying attention to staying away
from the
prohibitions you're opening the door for
all the good things as well to to start
coming
in when you are in touch with
prohibitions and you constantly do them
you're not allowing the blessings the
baracas to come in even if you pray even
if you fast and there are a lot of
evidence in the Quran and the Sunnah
that I don't have time to go through all
of those but it is
possible number
three
stay
constantly with you know stick with the
prayers with duas with a recitation of
the Quran and with Vick
constantly I mentioned to you the Ayah
earlier why because does this or these
actions guarantee a connection with our
creator and I don't need to repeat it
right the the more you stay closer to
Allah the more you're connected with
safety blessings and all the other
things that I mentioned earlier that's
very
important I don't have time to do the
zck in the morning 10 minutes man that's
a long time don't be
realistic if it's going to be too much
don't one
minute make it two
minutes you're busy no problem just do
that but do it
constantly every day you go you go to
bed recite the
prayers I cannot do a j a day in the
Quran no problem do one page a
day do half a page a day if that's the
case so everybody based on their
abilities I don't have time to do so
many salawats do you have time to do 10
salawats every day do 10 salawats can
you do 70 times a day do 70 times a
day as long as you're doing constantly
because again what's the purpose behind
all of this is the connection is that
connection and you're showing to God at
the same time that I value you you come
first and I want to be connected with
you constantly because I want to benefit
from you
constantly and lastly but not
least stay in the company of righteous
people what helps us connect with Allah
subhana wa ta'ala constantly and boost
our spirituality help with our spir
spirituality is when we are in the
company of the righteous people
[Silence]
be
patient as you are dealing as you are in
the
company of
those servants those who are guided
already and who pray to Allah subhah wa
ta'ala during the day and during the
night as well these are people who are
constantly connected with Allah so be in
their company while practicing
patience man I'm going to this IM and I
want to sit with this guy and all of
that but all he talks is about Dean or
sometimes it's kind of you know
very serious and it's kind of hard you
know I'm not going to be able to do that
I have these other friends they're
religious they pray five times a day
nice people but my life is kind of
different it's very hard to kind of you
know do the way do things the way how
they do it I'm a little bit more wild
I'm on the wild
side it's not their problem it's your
problem you have to accommodate yourself
you have to transform yourself so you
can be in that company and enjoy that
company the Quran says
that be patient in being in their
company do not even take away your your
sight from them I constantly look at
them because when you are in their
company they remind you of Allah subhana
wa ta'ala when certain individuals you
look at them just by looking at them
they remind you of Allah subhana wa
tala don't take away looking at them for
a cheap price for worldly gains for
materialism for something that has no
value don't sell something that is so
important the company of the righteous
for something that has no value at
all Allah subhana wa ta'ala make us
among people who are sincere
Allah subhah wa ta'ala give us much
blessings during the month of rajab and
during the month of Shan and Deliver Us
safely into the month of
[Silence]
Ramadan for
Sudan
[Silence]
Allah abbar
turn up your lines please perform this
prayer with
[Silence]
devotion
Allah alhamd
Al
[Silence]
all
for
[Silence]
for for
Allah Allah
[Silence]
allahar alhamd
must
[Silence]
Allah
allar
allar allahar
all
[Silence]
as
brothers and sisters assalam
alaykum I have a very couple of very
important announcements please bear with
me also there is a shahada so please
stay with us for additional a
inshallah there's a book
signing this after this evening
inshallah after Isa byar
pardon
okay okay all right so if you buy the
book he can sign it right now so but
anyway there's going to be a group
discussion this evening inshallah
there's a panel discussion
Shear will be here for that and also
Sheik watk and Dr Lucas will be
joining for that conversation and that
will be enjoyable if you can please come
and join us the next announcement is
very important we need your help
brothers and sisters as you know we run
the rahma academy from here with your
funds with your money and the easiest
way to get that funds taken care of is
by the state of Arizona redirection of
the State of Arizona taxation now that
part is really lacking right now we I'm
really sad to to share with you that we
have received only $24,000 in pledges on
that program it is free of cost to you
now also I'm realizing that we have
until April the 15th to do this thing so
if you can please take the time and make
sure that your tax money whatever you
owe to the State of Arizona is directed
to the rahma academy so we can take care
of our children inshallah also the
mcct is offering a new program that's
going to be for youth Fitness club
alhamdulillah it's going to start
tonight after M and please join and get
more information from Imam Hass and
we're going to please donate generously
on the way out
and Hassan is going to request for I
think we have
shahada so we're trying to look at the
brother if brother Nikolai if you're
here please come to the front
brother Nikolai if you're here please
come to the
front it seems he's not
here all right inallah we'll see you
tonight inshallah we'll have some
refreshments for you guys in the gym so
please come join us
inshallah
[Silence]
e for